[Music]
when you're trying to clear clutter and
create outer order a really helpful
question to consider is are you an over
buyer or an under buyer and maybe you're
neither maybe you're just a middle buyer
but many people are over buyers or like
me they're under buyers so over buyers
are people who just love to buy they
shop they do errands they make lists if
they're going to travel they've got ten
things they need to buy if their kids
are going back to school they've got 15
supplies that they need they often will
rack up like big stockpiles of slow
moving things like toothpaste or soup
they'll do things like buy something
that's gonna make a wonderful gift they
don't know who they're gonna give it to
exactly but it seems like a wonderful
gift or they buy things in multiple
colors or they buy a lot of things on
sale and being an over buyer means that
often you have a lot of errands and
tasks that you feel like you need to do
you can run out of space because you've
got all the stuff that you need to store
and manage you can lose track of how
much you have of something because you
keep buying a hammer you don't realize
that you have five hammers and you can
spend a lot of money on things that you
don't really need yet and you can even
run into the problem of waste where like
something like a scented candle gets
kind of goes bad even before you use it
or you're able to give it away or some
kind of medicine expires before you even
get to the point of using that bottle of
medicine so if you're an over buyer you
want to say to yourself hang on do I
really need to buy this thing maybe I
can store it at the store I will leave
that extra bottle of toothpaste at the
store and I can get it when I need it
because I'm going to store it at the
store and I'm gonna hold myself back now
there are also under buyers under buyers
are people like me we don't like to shop
we don't like to spend and we will often
go to kind of extraordinary and silly
lengths to avoid it under under buyers
typically don't like to buy specialized
prod products for instance for a long
time I didn't have a raincoat why do you
need a coat specifically for rain I
didn't buy Kleenex
I can just blow my nose in toilet paper
why do I need a special tissue paper to
blow my nose I don't believe in
conditioner I don't use shaving cream
there's a lot of things where I just
don't want to buy something now being an
under buyer is good in some ways because
you save yourself a lot of money and
you're and you don't run as men run that
many errands but it can also be
inconvenient because under buyers often
don't have things until the very last
minute and then it can be difficult to
get them like if you wait for the very
last minute to buy mittens the store
often doesn't have mittens anymore
they've moved on um often under buyers
are making do with things that are kind
of shabby aren't really suitable for
their purpose like maybe it would be
nice to use shaving cream to shave
instead of using soap or whatever my
makeshift solution would be and under
buyers often too are very inconvenience
because they are running out of
toothpaste they are running out of
saline solution there's things where you
know it doesn't hurt to have a couple
spare rolls of toilet paper somewhere in
your house or apartment so that you're
not always doing everything just in time
and so that's one thing
under buyers need to remember is it to
encourage themselves to buy to look for
opportunities we're spending and buying
could make their lives easier and more
convenient and here's the other thing
about clutter and under buyers you might
think to yourself well under buyers
won't have clutter because they don't
like to buy and spend no often under
buyers have just as much clutter as over
buyers because under buyers hate the
idea of having to go out and buy
something and the idea like ooh I
haven't worn this black jacket in six
years can I get rid of it and I think
well gosh but imagine that a situation
arose where I needed a black jacket hehe
that I would have to go out and buy a
black jacket is awful to me I hate that
idea so I better hang on to everything
because I could imagine a scenario where
just about anything in my life could
come in handy because I don't want to
risk that I might one day want to make
bread with a bread maker I want to hang
on to that bread maker even though I
haven't used it in five years and so one
thing underwires have to remember is
sometimes you just have to let things go
and take the risk
that you might actually just have to go
to a store and buy something whether
you're an over buyer or whether you're
an under wire is going to influence the
kind of clutter that you have and when
you understand that you're much better
able to figure out how to manage clutter
for yourself telling an underwire that
they should buy less well they don't
need that advice because they're already
not buying they need different advice
and same thing with over buyers they
need to think about themselves when they
think about creating the outer order in
the way that's right for them
you